haben Sie schon lange keine Briefe mehr
gekauft bekommen könnte an der Deutschen
Post liegen und an nichts anderem
teilweise wochenlang keine Briefe im
Briefkasten das ist die große Post Wut
und sie haben dieser Wut längst Luft
gemacht bei uns Post Kunden ja die haben
schon mit uns gesprochen jetzt sprechen
die Post Zusteller die Briefträger hier
bei Bild
die Post Posse geht in die nächste Runde
nachdem Bild über die desaströse
zustellbilanz der Deutschen Post
berichtete melden sich nun die
Paketzusteller zu Wort aus Angst vor dem
Jobverlust äußern sich die Angestellten
anonymen im Blatt und während sich
Überstunden abbauen ich bin froh wenn
ich Urlaub bekomme
ich hatte eine Rücken-OP und muss
trotzdem bis zu 31,5 Kilogramm schwere
Pakete schleppen ich verdiene 2000 Euro
netto fange dafür morgens um kurz nach 5
Uhr an und höre kurz vor 17 Uhr auf
Christina Dahlhaus Chefin der
kommunikationsgewerkschaft DPV legt den
Finger in die Wunde die Deutsche Post
macht einfach eine völlig falsche
Personalpolitik es ist mittlerweile
sogar so dass fast 10.000 Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die Post selber verlassen
haben aufgrund der schlechten
Arbeitsbedingungen wir haben einen hohen
Krankenstand der immer zweistellig ist
schon seit Jahren und seit Jahren fehlen
im Grunde Zusteller wer mit einer
befristungsquote arbeitet von fast 20
Prozent jeder fünfte und sechste ist
befristet die Menschen also nicht hält
die Arbeitsbedingungen immer schwieriger
werden der muss sich nicht wundern dass
ein hoher Krankenstand da ist das B die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Unternehmen
verlassen weil sie nicht mehr können und
wenn die Arbeitsbedingungen nicht besser
werden dann kommt auch keiner
zustelldebakel Zusteller Frust es wird
deutlich marode Strukturen frustrierte
Mitarbeiter eine Neustrukturierung muss
her aber bitte ohne Lieferprobleme
[Musik]